We've just reached an entire new milestone
in space exploration. "A mission to go to
a comet, drill out a sample, and bring it
back to Earth." The European Space Agency's
Rosetta spacecraft just landed a small, 220-pound
robot onto a comet, making it the 7th celestial
body we've ever landed a spacecraft on. Previous
missions have flown by comets, and in 2005,
NASA intentionally crashed a spacecraft into
a comet to analyze its interior, but this
is the first mission to make a controlled
landing on one. Comets are frigid chunks of
ice and rock that orbit the sun. They're a
bit like asteroids, except they have more
elliptical orbits that sometimes take them
so close to the sun that they start to vaporize,
creating the bright tails they're known for.
Scientists think comets may have brought water
and complex organic molecules to Earth, which
we can thank for our existence. The comet
in question is called 67P/C-G, named after
the Ukrainian astronomers who first spotted
it in 1969. It's sort of duck shaped and about
2.5 miles wide. Picture a rock the size of
Japan's Mt. Fuji, rotating every 12 hours
and moving through space at about 84,000 miles
per hour, millions of miles away from Earth.
Comet 67P orbits the sun every 6 and a half
years from a point just beyond Jupiter. To
reach it, Rosetta had to loop around several
times, passing by Earth and Mars to use their
gravity as a slingshot. As a result, it's
been traveling for more than a decade. It
left Earth way back in March 2004 and has
traveled over 3.5 billion miles to reach the
comet. That's nearly 40 times the distance
from the Earth to the sun. As it traveled
too far to be powered by the sun, the spacecraft
went into hibernation for 2.5 years on the
way there. Rosetta woke up at the beginning
of this year and caught up with the comet
in August. Just putting the probe in orbit
around the comet was a major feat -- we'd
never done that before -- especially since
engineers expected a potato-shaped comet,
and ended up with a duck. Last month, scientists
picked out a site for the lander, a nice smooth
flat spot on the comet's smaller lobe. The
lander flew down to the comet over the course
of several hours, slowing itself down and
eventually landing at the speed of a person
walking. "Here we have very very low gravity.
So this lander, which has a mass of about
100kg, will have the weight of about a sheet
of paper when it comes down on the comet.
The problem is to stay there." After 10 years
of flight, the lander has an incredibly short
amount of time to conduct science on the comet's
surface: 64 hours. That's how long its battery
lasts, and that's how long it has to drill
into the comet, collect soil samples, and
chemically analyze them. After that, the lander
deactivates unless it can get enough solar
power to recharge. But Rosetta will continue
to orbit the comet and keep sending back photos
and other data until December 2015, when the
comet heads back out of the inner solar system.
All this research will tell us more about
the composition of comets than we've ever
known before. And because comets are the oldest
things we can reach, this information could
help us better understand the very beginnings
of our solar system.